under ice e tata
rio diana com muito e não pula daquela
boca
então o que nós fazemos um pequeno
exercício vai ser um pouco da china
eu vou pedir para vocês irem pra você
faz buscar os gostos pensa em cédulas
mas gustavo não tem essa imagem
buscamos nossos filhos favor guarda
segura essa imagem príncipe presente
novamente
eu amei dispõe de nove mesmo de cair
pelas cenas que ela fazendo os filmes eu
estava caidinho não tem o príncipe
encantado
o meu era jackson eu achava normal eu
idolatrava mas porque era tudo que eu
tinha
na verdade todas as tvs e rádios para
apresentar o aluno como eram televisões
ou novelas filmes que fazia assim como
todo o pessoal pra 87 tem 32 anos de
idade então já sabe né
esta representa comigo sabe disso e
achava normal mas já é um cinema
perguntar porque é que ninguém dos meus
ídolos inclusão no dia que o código é
parecido com ninguém por perto do meio
dia
não vou comentar
[Música]
agora com zé não né
eu também não me vejo fazendo então isso
só fazendo fora muito aqui dentro eu
represento como uma pessoa
o problema não é um problema mal mas
problema problema que se resolve a minha
jornada um pouco diferente de muita
gente eu não estava com o cabelo crédito
muita gente quando começa a jornada
também o grêmio já estava com o cabelo
crescer muito
william 8 o penteado
eu era criança depois começou a jornada
na adolescência por quatro produtos a
quem tão linda que os oitos dos olhos de
quem vivia
todo mundo achou bonita de os cabelos
bem aquilo é o ideal
aquilo era o que achava bonita
comecei a minha fase adulta
a primeira vez como representante em
portugal da marca já ouviram falar do
filme porque tanto a gente daquela
senhora na cara
eu nunca vir me pedir um filme eu
assistia nenhuma novela é a minha
primeira representação
agora já estou a ficar tudo espero né
representação muito bonito né
representado escuridão é uma coisa
a fundadora e membro da chamada black
label descobrir
a representação social em nosso país
outro inspira oi gente virar e é por
isso que me chamaram de técnico ea isso
é o prefeito dois meses da apresentação
é outro influencia e é influenciada não
é
não tem como ser o edson que são aquelas
que vão além da televisão nas lives do
mais nós os seres humanos significa
acontecer um negócio aqui a minha que
estava no vasco começa aí é que aquela
pessoa que está na televisão uma música
no videoclipe está a fazer a representar
alguém mais novo que eu estou a fazer é
apresentar
não sei que vai apresentar pela
televisão já aplicadas a rádio e também
nunca cria um problema onde ele segue
sob o tema igrejas ensaios fotográficos
o primeiro na verdade falava mais de mim
quando eu vim a xingava e falar eu só
quero mesmo é natural
pega a internet hoje que não integrava
mais pessoas e de crédito e conseguiu
conter o choro quando eu trouxe gênero
diversidade de cabelo de velocidade à
defesa
vamos falar de outras raças já estou a
falar da nossa negra
somos tão diferentes dos outros e temos
várias tonalidades e aí quando o sol do
problema que é o segundo muito você quer
ter de nos relacionarmos pulseira preto
sempre algo negativo
ora vejamos ou não seja uma longa data
marca a fruta já viram uma muleta
acho que vem aí não eu conheço uma
mulata que vem no formato e málaga
graças a deus uma representa uma mulata
uma mana representa celular porque não
ligamos o ser negro ser feito
não estou falando da tonalidade de pele
foca-se tonalidade de pelo ser feito com
muita coisa negativa outro exemplo
quando você comeu mão por mais que você
tenha qualquer tonalidade de pele se
torna nacionais cinco estrelas estou a
comer a minha cima mão porque me apetece
boxe gajo é preto
mesmo que tenha outras tonalidades de
pela mãe
a ok porque essa relação
espera aí somos foi um gosto
nós passamos a gostar das pessoas mais
clarinhas do que dos masculinos porque
acordamos decidimos se um sistema tem um
sistema agrada-nos o que vamos fazer
para mudar já estão prontos para mudar
isso que tá
tiramos todo estereótipos ligados com as
suas mais escuras e também com as
mulatas
nós temos vários protótipos eu não vou
falar dos motivos que nós temos aqui
final fecha o meu canal é que no texas
temos vários estereótipos que estão
ligados somente a raça negra é o que me
interessa agora vamos lá retirar isso
sabem por que nossos filhos estão
ouvindo e preto é feio
nossos filhos estão a ouvir e ter cabelo
crespo é para pobre e eles vão continuar
a seguir a mesma trajetória que a gente
conseguiu aqui pela mudança começa
conosco mesmo a palavra representação na
verdade pra mim significa inspirar
nós temos que ser inspiradas por coisas
melhores pra ser melhor mas quando
perguntávamos o que tu queres ser quando
for grande
quando éramos crianças a primeira coisa
que é médico professora hospedeiro a
hospedeira ó hospedeira porque são as
coisas que nós tenhamos respostas são as
coisas que a gente tem no dia a dia nos
nossos orgulhos se significa que a
representação na televisão e vários
sítios
importa sim nos temos que estar
representados dread locks
eu não vou falar o que falou andrade
logo mas vocês sentem representados ou
seja agora vamos lá voltar
será que eu represento
vamos deixar para o outro
eu me representa
como é que é essa cena eu carmen não vou
falar que a peruca é má mas como é que
eu carmen me visto claro a minha pena
muda o meu cabelo muda o meu tom falou
mal do preto que eu estou a representar
o que eu estou a passar o que eu estou
inspira
eu só vou pedir ao paulatina menta para
tirarmos tudo negativo relacionado
é difícil é um tema muito chato é
difícil vocês não relacionar é o preto
com algo negativo mas chegou o momento
chegou o momento de a gente começar a
exigir mais respeito a nós mesmos
não interessa o tom de pele eu não posso
ser subjugada pelo meu tom de perda e
parem de falar de racismo estou a falar
da raça negra ou seja entre nós entre
nós vamos parar de texto tipos com dread
locks dread locks não defini a minha
inteligência dread locks não defini a
minha capacidade de influenciar o
indivíduo eu falar de influência já
agora todos os dias quando eu acordo eu
digo para meu filho fez bonito preto
meu cabelo bonito
ele sempre da mesma forma sorri me
abraça
eu vou parar por aqui
[Música]